[Music]
you started coming on our show a late
night show years and years ago when you
were virtually unknown you become this
huge movie star huge it stands true
you you're self-deprecating but girls
shriek for you i hear shrieking i hear
uh he's usually shrieking like near me
i'm usually walking past tragedies so no
no not related to me no no no it is
related to you do you find that
flattering uh that uh oh i don't think
it happens but um no i i don't think i
would find it flattering either it's
like terrifying when somebody's
screaming at you
it's like screaming like a human nature
thing it's like
well i'm just curious you're very
convincing in this movie i really like
the film you're very convincing uh doing
magic clearly you you had to learn magic
to play this role this terrific magician
did you i mean was your exposure to
magic growing up were you one of those
kids that was into magic um no no
because i couldn't understand magic i i
my mother was like a birthday party
clown when i was growing up so um hold
it let's back it up for a second sure
you can't just say that and then move
forward you know my mom learned that
birthday party party yeah and my dad
michael jordan um
so wait so
she was a birthday she she would she'd
perform at like kids birthdays but you
know she didn't perform at mine because
the illusion would have been broken
because i'm her son so she bartered with
the local magician uh who performed at
my birthday parties in exchange for like
a free party for you know his family and
so um i knew this magician welcomes my
mother's friend but he also performed at
my birthday and i remember like not
understanding what he was doing like i
never understood like what the actual
trick was like he pulled a rabbit out of
a hat and i just thought like well yes
of course a rabbit would come out of a
hat and then all the kids around me were
like amazed and i was just bewildered
you were bewildered by magic because
there's this pressure to see what it is
i mean rabbit out of a hat that's pretty
obvious but card trick i'm always
nervous when i'm watching a card trick
that i'm going to get my part wrong
right pressure and then when they go huh
yeah i just you know what i mean
yeah i think that's probably why a lot
of magicians work really well because
the people don't remember what their
card was they just say yes that's yeah
please let me get the f out of here uh
magicians are good liars i think you
have to be a good liar to be a magician
don't you yeah
and also dexterous yes you have to be
well obviously you need that skill but
you need the skill of being able to
misdirect people deceive them is that
something that you would be good at no
i'm not good at that no no i mean i i
you know i spent like four months
learning magic for the movie and i would
perform for the crew you know there was
a lot of guys working on the movie
usually big big men and um
i would do like a trick for them and
immediately feel guilty and uh
threatened so like um
you know in the middle of the trick
reveal how it was done
that's the worst magician ever yeah yeah
basically i have one in my pocket you'll
see it yeah yeah it's gone
but you won't see it but you're going to
see it it's a bad magician but a good
friend yeah good friend but i think that
you feel bad doing a good magic trick
for people it's like yeah it's deceitful
no no it's just entertainment i know i
realized it and then when i would tell
them what the trick was they were
disappointed so i realized like magic is
fun and you should not reveal the
secrets yeah yeah i wouldn't think you
should well there's at this uh some
great locations you shot part of this on
uh bourbon street during mardi gras yeah
yeah and and
really uh fantastic scenes is this was
this shot with are those all extras are
those all people in the movie because it
looked like these some of these crowd
scenes are huge yeah yeah we filmed like
on bourbon street and i think like half
the people were hired by the movie to
like act like they were crazy and then
the other half of the people were crazy
and um i remember i was like running
through bourbon street and every time i
passed this woman well i passed this
woman and she she lifted up her shirt
and i thought i hope they tell her you
know that we're filming here and that
would be really embarrassing to her
parents for them to see it and
everything and then i ran past her again
like in the second take and she did the
same thing and i realized oh she's she's
been hired to do that oh yeah yeah
yeah i love your reaction to a woman
lifting your shirt oh good hair
you're the sweetest guy i've met in show
business ever i've said this about you
over the years i know there's no one
nice than just eisenberg but a girl
lifting her top you're like oh her
parents this could be scarring well
and i phone calls should be made
letters should be written i apologize to
get from my parka
cover up young lady please have your
from another century that's what's so
nice about you i did for my knickers
which actually doesn't fit over the top